igen hát szerintem az egyik nagy
kihívása és ezt a ezt a kérdést én is
megkaptam hogy hogy akkor a keresztény
vállalkozó vállalkozásában csak
keresztények dolgozhatnak és és mi
történik hogyha hogyha valaki más
ideológiai háttérrel jön vagy egyszerűen
csak úgy gondolja hogy ez ezt kint kell
hagyni a cégen kívül
igen hát a az én válaszom erre az
egyértelműen nem tehát hogy hogy alkal
unk a cégünkhöz nem keresztény elvek
alapján élő személyeket is pontosabban
akik nem tehát nem kell egy ilyen ilyen
hiszek egyet felmondani a az
állásinterjú és nem kell egyetértsen
velünk mindenben viszont alázatos kell
legyen ami egy keresztény érték alázatos
kell legyen hogy minden nem tudhat